the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we're given this definition for car
we saw that in the previous slide I want
to add a method that's going to change
the color of the car and these are my
four four choices and it looks like you
guys are getting it getting it right
which is awesome okay so to find a
method to change the color of the car
which does this so we know that self has
to be the first parameter so we can
automatically eliminate and see and it's
between B and D and remember I said you
have to be conscious about whose data
attribute you're accessing and in this
case we want to change the color of a
particular instance of the car right so
we have to say self color instead of
just color if we just said color then
color would refer to just a variable
inside the class not a data attribute of
a particular object